all right amanda yes sir amanda where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally i'm from kansas city missouri
kansas city and uh tell me about your
childhood you had both your parents when
you were young yeah no i had my my
father raised five kids my um mother
left us
like
i was what i think i was only five i
have five brothers i'm the only girl
so
and my mom left us my mom just passed
away last year my 19 year old son has
passed away with terminal stomach cancer
like three months ago
my dad's gone my stepmom's gone i'll
i'll have all my brothers but i don't
get along with him too much because
it's a long strong talk about that
because that brings back too much
[ __ ] but anyway
how was your childhood you my childhood
was pretty it was okay but i i was in
and out of juvenile a lot you know
so run away from home you know we live
far out in the middle of nowhere so you
know i
i was bored you know so i just ran away
from home i saw my mom and dad's car
when i was younger
i've you know
i've been through a lot you know
i was
i was 15 13 years old when i first
started
working the street
um guy gave me five grand
how much five grand five thousand for my
virginity at 13.
and nobody knows this my brothers don't
notice my dad nobody knows this i'm
barely
filling it out um
i live in lancaster with um this guy
named eddie peterson he's a [ __ ] he's
only three foot two when he was blinded
in a wheelchair but i took really really
good care of him
and one night i went out to go work and
um
i got a car just getting leonard earl
bells
and
you guys can look it up and tell you
everything that man did to me um
he killed three women in lancaster i'm
the only one that survived he killed
three women yeah in lancaster i'm the
only one
18 years he did 18 years in 10th century
and they still let him out they didn't
think he was going to do nothing he did
he ended up
trying to kill me um whenever i got in
the car with him
i'll give him some head next thing you
know i'm standing up in the seat with a
dog leaves you around my neck
that's how fast he choked me and i
didn't even realize what's going on he
stripped me butt naked took everything
from my money my phone my jewelry
everything
then i put my clothes back on
then he put a shirt over my face so
we went we were in course here we went
to um this house gopal right he was
doing uh remodeling this house
for a pastor of a church
the windows inside the house were
bulletproof so anything you changed me
nobody could hear
you know so i just went along with what
he had done to me
because i didn't want to get hurt
and
he hugged me and threw me in a bathtub
he repeated me for
hours it took me six and a half hours
to get out the hog time
to use my leggings to tie my my feet to
my hand
and
in the kitchen
in the kitchen
or the thing here you know how you
slaughter pigs that hook thing he had
not a big little one hanging from there
[Music]
and when you see him in the bathroom he
told me he says i might come back and
give you some water and food and says oh
by the way i have a baby monitor out
outside the bathroom door so if you try
to escape i'm gonna hear you a baby
monitor only go at least a hundred
hundred to two hundred feet so one once
i heard his car drive off but i was
still scared
it took me six and a half hours ago
my every blood that's where my eye was
broken
my face was looked like an alien purp
purple
my feet were my feet look like fred
flint's own feet they were so swollen
my arms my hands my whole body [ __ ] up
um
anyway um
then um
that same day they they caught him you
know the reason why they caught him was
because
we went to the bank to a bank
and um
they see me and him standing together at
that time i had a broken arm my arm was
messed up
but they got him to give 164 years in
the penitentiary how many years 164.
he'll never get out he'll never get up
never see streets again
but then they said that one girl that
another girl did make it but she
wouldn't show up for court she went
that's fine but he ain't never getting
out anyway
but the
first court date i went to i
i was terrified
i had dreams and i was gonna jump over
the table and stab me with a pencil
and james got out he's going to kill me
i mean
my mental
is so messed up you know i tried to
situations that have been done to me
you know
so back to your childhood was there
anything in your childhood that kind of
yeah but i don't want i
i don't want to discuss that okay
i really don't because
then it'll be a more issue with me and
my family so yeah
but um and then another time
i um thrown into a car by a pimp
his mom let me out struggle the car you
know what i'm saying
i've been
i was raised by a guy down here
three years ago big old fat guy in a
blue van
i've never seen him again after that
i've been doing some stuff so you stay
you staying scared right now you're
staying on skid row now
yeah
if i would have
stayed with
my ex i've been all right i left my ex
for somebody else and this one and
person that i left him for
was no good i thought he was he treated
me like a queen at first then
went back to his ex-girlfriend dummy
like i was
[ __ ] i tried to speak to him today when
he talked to me so
and then i was called my wrath he knew
what he was doing i fell in love with
him but i was helping him i was
going out to making money you know what
i'm saying and helping out you know you
know yeah i i i smoke broccoli yes i do
but i said anything i don't but i got a
head on my shoulders i'm not stupid
do you have children i got three kids um
josh and georgie
and where are they from what i know
supposedly my son has died of cancer
at 19 years old i don't know for sure i
don't know what's going on
i haven't seen my kids over like 17
years
none of them my daughter talked to me
treat me like [ __ ]
no no i've
i've talked about getting a long time
but if i was just saying
would glenn bradley i'd have been all
right about his name with china i mean
all right
because he tried he tried
so hard to work with me
every time i
just run off like it's nothing and just
run off and leave him you know
it's not fair to him
is that your biggest regret
is that you sound like you might have
some regrets that might be that's one of
my biggest figures because he tried so
hard
to get me straight to be with me
do you wanna ask your phone now
when i just phoned for you
and the other guy who just went around
here like it's nothing so
it's not
anybody fun loves my heart
really hard
crack cocaine you discovered at what
point
i wish i never i wish today so i could
just get off of it
i was what i'm 41 i was
i think 30 about 30 31
but i wish i never started
they're not easy to get off of
it's really not
and you've worked with pimps before it
sounds like you've worked with pimps
before it sounds like
i went through a pimp for 22 years
i still talk to him every now and then
but
i'll never
but he's like my best friend we always
got along
always got along
but he moved out of state when he moved
out of state it's like he don't come
back i don't you know
it's
it's horrifying mark i've been through
so much
i miss my i miss my stepmom and my room
my funeral i went to my dad's
you know what i went through dad's room
because i'm i'm the only girl so i would
you know daddy's little girl
you talking with your family at all i
talked to my brothers all the time
some of my me and my brother kenneth are
the closest i talked to my my little
brother elvin didn't pay attention to
her 20 years for self-defense in his own
home
i haven't been in i've not been in jail
in [ __ ]
maybe three years
but i keep doing what i'm doing i'm
gonna go back
you know and i don't want to
tell me about the johns that you pick up
here on schedule
tell me about your the tricks that you
pick up on skid row
really
i know about the tricks on figueroa
street but the skid road
the ones on gating things are not the
best ones down here yeah down here tell
me about that guys down here one
there was one of them
i forgot to name it but anyway
we were getting high
well he was getting high i met you i
wanted it
and you wanted some hate he gave me you
know four dollars or whatever well he
gave him some head
and he jumped out the car where i was
going
right the car was going he pushed me and
opened the door jumped up
so i had to jump in the driver's side
you know i'm seeing
and i ended up hitting
his car end up hitting another car you
know what i'm saying from him
tripping out i mean i had one guy
what's in hotel with him
and we'll see him try to get under bed
said somebody was coming to get him so
he tried to call him can't crawl under
the [ __ ] the bed with the wood you
know what the worst part
i had one guy curl up in a bathtub in a
fetal position
i mean all your all your customers must
be high
a lot of them are a lot of them i have
one no i have what
i've been doing this one for 17 years
[Music]
um
i don't know what happens
over nine and i have another one for 13
years
it's good to have regulars i have a lot
of regulars i really do
the guys out here are mostly mexicans it
don't matter to me no no
skid row they're mostly mexican i would
think
no no not really
all sorts of it's you know what on again
because i wear my aggregate agatha is
the street where
the girls are man
money is money is good over here at
night is that right
how much money i've made two grand in
two weeks
two grand in two weeks in two weeks i've
you know obtained
no that that's not a whole lot of money
but how much yes
so if if a guy comes rolls by and picks
you up and wants a quick date how much
is that
for him i charge 80.
but [ __ ] i drive 125.
and usually i get it
mm-hmm
are you ever asked to do this without a
condom or like that all the time
and i i i i'm not lying
i can show you right now i got a
personal comment
i get condoms like it ain't nothing
i got condoms i mean
i got so many condoms in here
keeps you alive huh keeps you alive
yeah i do because i i can't take no
chances nobody i i can't take a risk
i was already crazy by somebody down
here and i had um
board the baby because i
got hit by a car this
guy jumped out of the car and he hit me
65 miles an hour
from behind tried to kill me on purpose
but
you know
[Music]
i've been i've been doing too much mark
i don't know how much more i can take
you know what's what emotions do you go
through after
your rough life i go through a lot of
emotions i go through a lot you
depressed a lot
i'm you know i'm a happy person all the
time i'm i always try to be happy
but
what really [ __ ] me i just went
like with this guy i really liked that
guy yeah i really did
feel like you screwed that up
well yeah i was only gone for one night
but i still came back like it wasn't
money but that wasn't the point
hopefully i should have been there with
him period right
so he let me let me go back to his
ex-girlfriend which treats him like [ __ ]
i can't stand her i don't like the way
she treats him
she treats him [ __ ] horrible
and it makes it makes me just want to
walk downstream just tear her [ __ ]
head off because he's a good [ __ ] man
he's a good guy
so i got out of any man that i've been
with that man
has been the best
person i've ever been with
and i'm not gonna lie i'm not gonna
sugarcoat it but it's a goddamn truth
he really is
he ignores me like i'm nobody down you
know i don't think that's right at least
we can leave me friends
oh
when you're a young girl were there did
you have dreams of doing something with
your life no well oh yeah i wanted to be
a veterinarian i still want to be
mid-area
i like animals
it's such a dangerous lifestyle you're
leading
you know what i i really wish that i
could
it's not that easy to get off this [ __ ]
it's not
you think you're addicted to the
the lifestyle and the drugs and i mean
there's no money
know i'm addicted to the streets
that's my life the streets the streets
of my life and you know what
it's not something that
i should be doing
my brother can't worry so much about me
and my nephew
i have never seen my nephew ethan i
always talk to him on the phone but that
little boy loves the hell and he always
always wants to talk to me oh
oh that's a dad dad where's anamanda
when she coming you know
that shouldn't inspire me to stop but he
don't
i mean it doesn't don't i'll stop but
then i'll relapse
what was the best time of your life
the best time in my life
i was just a baby and diapers [ __ ]
it's all been downhill from there oh man
i've been through so much [ __ ] mark
and my ex-boyfriend they killed him
uh his name was slim they killed him
and um
we got too big of a fight in a motel and
he tried to choke me with a towel
that was some [ __ ] man
i had one one trick was 250 pounds jump
on top me
i i just i had to stab down my foot like
three or four times to get him up off me
and i didn't want to do that but i got
himself again
i got three i carried three knives on
right
because i don't know what's gonna happen
a lot of girls get killed out here
doing what you do
yeah that's what i'd be scared of
sometimes
what do you think is the most
misunderstood thing about girls that
work the street that you know what the
i've been out since i was 13 i'm 41
years old
i've been through a lot of [ __ ] the
probably half these girls haven't been
through
i have you know a few times on days to
say talk to a couple other young girls
and tell them i've told them my story
oh well we ain't worried about ain't
gonna happen to us you don't know what
could happen to you
the only advice i can give to a girl is
be careful watch back
if you if you get into a car with
somebody always before you get in the
car shake the hand first because that's
going to tell you if they got to go to
or or not that's how i determine but
i've been wrong
i've been wrong i've been fooled i'm
wrong your intuition isn't perfect it
went perfect but i'm telling you
and i feel bad for these little girls
there's this one lady that came out
gabe's a figural anna
she could find her daughter for
about five six months
cold part about him when she showed me a
picture of her daughter i had to got the
girl in my motel room the day before
that i fed her helped out bought her
drugs whatever she looked out for her
and she ended up coming up dead two days
later
you think there's a better chance that
you'll get your
self straight clean
i hope so i really do or anything
there's a better chance of you dying
i want you it's just so hard working
hard
and you got [ __ ] like
do you think there's a better chance of
getting clean or dying
i you know i can't predict that because
i don't know
i still don't know what i what i want i
know that i want to be clean it's
already i do but it's not easy
it's hard
i know my ex-wife sonia found a winner
for 17 years
she's always tell me
i worry about you all the time you know
when i say i worry about you all the
time
i'll never know if i'm ever gonna
wake up and i get a phone call
my brother's coming at too all the time
it's not
you think you get desensitized to all
the dangers out here do you think you
get desensitized to all the dangers out
here what do you mean by that you just
you just
proceed as usual every night you're out
here you don't realize how dangerous it
is and it just kind of becomes i do i
realize it but it it's
it's normal for me like everybody told
me you still walk around here with your
head up like there's nothing
like nothing happened to you
i got hit by by a car well i can't lift
up my shirt because i got an underwear
on
but
right here in my arm i got a squat right
here i got a scarf from here all the way
down mark
your your knee is covering your business
you can lift it up
oh would i give you
good
i'll blur it out
will you i'll blur that
a metal plate in each one of my arms
i have two metal bars right here
i have one lung
my spleen is paper thin that means
anybody wants me to hit me really hard i
could die and wait
i've been through some [ __ ] man and a
couple of i didn't even do nothing to
that boy for that boy to do this to me
somebody else did it not me then when he
finds out that he's going to finally
realize that he didn't do it [ __ ] you
got me [ __ ] up
now you know i ain't reporting it
because
he's got a daughter he just got cussing
his daughter
and every time i see him with his
daughter it makes me think of me and my
kids
i would hate for that little girl don't
have a dad
and i hope he sees this you know i'm not
revealing his name
tell you only because of your daughter
that's why you're not in prison that's
the only reason
you're not imprisoned because of your
daughter even though you've been gone a
long time ago but i don't need the
police in my business but for real
i thought you were my friend and i was
wrong
amanda what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in all
your years of doing this
to respect people
respect
respect comes a long way
if you don't give the person same
respect you get anything can happen to
you
respect
respect comes a long way
a long way if you're not respectful
nobody gonna have nothing or decency you
gotta have respect you can see
self-control of certain things that you
do
i mean
i learned a lot out here in the street
i say one thing my ex my ex pimp taught
me so much [ __ ]
that
i just
i didn't know what i know now you know
and he's my my best friend all my world
it was you know never stopped me my
friend
never
now always be there for him no matter
what because he was always there for me
he never put his hands on me and they
were talking to me none of that was
always different regardless every time
he needed help i was the only [ __ ]
known on his side
besides another girl but
all right amanda thank you so much for
sharing your story you're welcome
be careful out there
every time i walk out this
time i walk around i'd be scared anyway
mark